منذ وصول اللاجئين السودانيين الى داخل
الاراضي التشاديه وهم على هذا الحال
تدبروا امرهم تحت هذه الاشجار لتقيهم من
الحر بانتظار ان تقدم لهم المنظمات
الانسانيه اعانات
مناطقهم الاصليه التي غادروها من السودان
الى هنا في هذا الموقع داخل الاراضي
الشعبيه تبعد بنحو عده مئات من الامثال
فقط
كثير منهم غادر منطقته تحسبا لان يعتدي
عليهم احد طرفي الحرب السودانيه او ان
تشتعل حرب بين القبائل في هذه المنطقه
وتقدر المنظمات الانسانيه عدد اللاجئين
السودانيين الذين وصلوا الى كاد حتى الان
باكثر من عشره الاف شخص كما تقدر عددا
الذين يصلون يوميا الى داخل الاراضي
التجاريه بمئات الاشخاص
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره من منطقه قدره على
الحدود التجاريه السودانيه